First, the kill test.
Doug.
[music playing]
Welcome to our
kilij kill test.
[laughs]
To see what kind of lethal
damage your weapon will do,
I will take your kilij
and deliver killing
blows this large side of beef.
Let's see how deadly
your weapons are.
Connor, you're up first.
You ready?
I don't know.
Let's do it anyways.
Let's do this.
I'm excited to see
Doug attack this carcass.
My only real concern is how
Doug feels about the handle.
Because if it's not comfortable,
then it's not a good blade.
[rock music playing]
Nice.
[exhales]
Connor, your blade is sharp.
This lacerates deep
into that meat carcass.
One issue I had a little
bit was with the handle.
On the first impact,
I felt it rotate
so I had to adjust with it.
But this, sir, will kill.
Thank you, sir.
Brian, you're up next.
You ready?
Absolutely.
Let's go.
Let's do this.
[rock music playing]
Nice.
Sweet.
Yeah.
First, off the bat,
that's a sharp blade.
It's so curved over here with
the bounce being forward allows
for a slicing action that
digs in and continues to cut
as I'm drawing the blade.
The handle feels good in the
hand to where I can index
and tell where it is
cutting all the time.
It will kill.
- Nice.
Thanks.
Thank you.
Next up, the strength test.
J [inaudible]?
OK.
This is going to be fun.
Here we go.
Tons of fun.
As you see, we've got
some nice, sturdy oak
barrels over here.
So what I'm going to do is take
your finely crafted weapons
and bash them repeatedly
into these barrels.
Now, what the blades do to the
barrel doesn't really matter.
What matters is what the
barrel does to your blade.
Connor, you're up.
You ready?
Uh, sure, let's--
let's do this.
[sighs]
[rock music playing]
[shouting]
Oh.
Connor, we've got a
couple of problems here.
Your blade torqued
out to one side.
[exhales]
The other concern I
have is your handle.
My hand is numb.
There was so much shock
coming through here.
And your handle tapers
from front to back.
So any time I'm
swinging, my pinkie
is slamming into the back end.
Yes, sir.
Brian, how you feeling?
You ready?
Oh, great.
I feel great.
- Oh, great?
- Let's do it.
- All right.
Let's go for it.
All right.
The sarcasm is overwhelming.
After watching J
beat on Connor's blade,
if I walk away from
this unscathed,
it's going to be a miracle.
[rock music playing]
[shouting]
Oh.
All right, Brian, got a little
bit of a wavy highway here.
A little bit.
Striking here, the whole blade
just kind of twisted around.
You're not going to be stabbing
straight with this thing
anymore.
But on the plus side, your
edge is still razor sharp.
Thank you.
Bladesmiths, you've both
done some amazing work.
But the judges'
deliberation is complete.
And they've chosen our next
"Forged in Fire" champion.
And that champion is--
Connor, congratulations.
You are our new "Forged
in Fire" champion.
Brian, your blade
didn't make the cut.
Now, Brian, I love
what you built for us.
But your blade took so much
damage during the strength test
that it wasn't able to perform
as well in the sharpness test.
And that's why we're
sending you home.
Understood.
Thank you.